if I was to ask you this one question
here watch this how many guys have a
four-year degree raisin if you got a
four-year degree okay
now watch this keep your hand up please
keep your hand up I'm really curious how
many of you that have a four-year degree
in the last 30 days you finished a
business book that's the problem
why so what's the point of a degree some
answers still up was it just to get a
degree in that education is gonna be
done you know what that's kind of like
me saying that's like me saying to
following when I was 14 to 18 years old
I exercise everyday and that's it come
on man is that how we stay in shape you
know I don't know why my six-pack is not
coming I used to have it when I was 22
I'm 42 no no we need to workout today
right we need to educate ourselves today
not what we did 20 years ago so I don't
have any problem with our people that
get degrees I have a problem with us not
endorsing self education I have a
problem with the fact that we need four
years to go to college nowadays where
snapchat comes out the next thing comes
out the next thing comes out we have to
move so quick that a four year degrees
too slow to school at our educational
system needs to be adjusted very very
quickly